BRET?
>> Bret: MORE ON ALL OF THIS
WITH THE PANEL.
JOHN, THANKS.
THE HEAD OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS
DEMANDING ANSWERS TONIGHT
ABOUT WHAT HE DESCRIBED AS,
QUOTE:  WHAT AMOUNTS TO A
COUP AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
BY TOP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE
HERRIDGE HAS DETAILS
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, CATHERINE.
>> THANK YOU, BRET AND GOOD
EVENING.
THE LETTER TO ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILLIAM BARR SEEKS
ALL RECORDS INCLUDING THE
SO-CALLED McCABE MEMOS
DRAFTED BY THE FORMER ACTING
FBI DIRECTOR.
THE REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN OF
THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE LINDSEY GRAHAM
SAID HE IS FORMALLY
INVESTIGATING ALLEGATIONS
THAT ANDREW McCABE, DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN AMONG OTHERS
DISCUSSED SECRETLY RECORDING
THE PRESIDENT AND INVOKING
THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
QUOTE:  THE COMMITTEE IS
DEEPLY CONCERNED WITH THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND WHETHER THEY
ESSENTIALLY INDICATE THE TWO
OF THE HIGHEST RANKING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS NUT
UNITED STATES WERE
DISGUSTING WHAT AMOUNTS TO A
COUP AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
ALSO TODAY, UNSEALED RECORDS
FROM A DEFAMATION CASE SHOW
HOW THE ANTI-TRUMP DOSSIER
WAS CIRCULATED BEFORE AND
AFTER THE 2016 ELECTION.
THE COURT RECORDS CONFIRM
THAT DAVID KRAMER THEN AN
AID TO THE LATE SENATOR JOHN
MCCAIN GAVE THE DOSSIER TO
BEEFED
BUEFED
BUZZED
BUZZFEED WELLS A DOZEN
REPORTERS.
HE WAS SINGLED OUT BY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE TO LAY
CREDIBILITY TO THE RESEARCH.
THE PROJECT WAS RUN BY GLENN
SIMPSON'S FUSION GPS.
QUOTE I THINK THEY FELT THE
SENIOR REPUBLICAN WAS BETTER
TO BE THE RECIPIENT OF THIS
RATHER THAN A DEMOCRAT
BECAUSE IF IT WERE A
DEMOCRAT, THE VIEW WAS THAT
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN DISMISSED
AS A POLITICAL ATTACK.
THE FBI'S FORMER
COUNTER-TERRORISM
INTELLIGENCE CHIEF BILL
PRIESTAP ALSO FILED A
DECLARATION CONFIRMING THE
FBI GOT THE DOSSIER FIRST 33
PAGES FROM MCCAIN IN
DECEMBER 2016.
THE FBI WAS ALREADY
RECEIVING THE MEMOS FROM
OTHER SOURCES.
PRESTEP ALSO CONFIRMED
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS BRIEFED
ON THE UNVERIFIED DOSSIER BY
SENIOR INTELLIGENCE